organized chaos is the way I I look
about my work in general but this is
also a way we call Cairo it's a way of
referring to Cairo as a chaotic but
somehow organized city so I I became my
my work as a as a photographer and very
early on I was involved with artists and
filmmakers from the Arab region just
after the war in Lebanon and around the
mid 90s and together we created and
founded the Arab image foundation which
today is quite a big institution in the
region that focuses on collecting
conserving and archiving photography
since the beginning of photography until
the end of the black and white era some
of the images that are part of the
collections are family images and studio
photography images these are really like
very random samples but I think it's
important to start with this sort of you
know the good old this is from a studio
in Iraq for example and the idea was to
try and figure out if there was such a
thing as Arab photography and a history
of Arab photography in a way that Arabs
had to look at themselves we were pretty
much drowning into this idea that you
know the West had looked at the Arab
world but we had we looked at ourselves
and so under the sort of pressure of
Orientalists views of the Middle East by
such photographers as you know very
famous Leonard and nan rock in Egypt for
example and the sort of image of what
people have of Egypt I thought instead
of you know instead of looking at my own
country as Orientalist did to look at my
country from the perspective of people
living there and so this was something
that it would never be possible today
but to picnic on top of K ups the
pyramid but I was inspired by this idea
of showing a different way of thinking
photography and the Middle East and
built very early on in my first when I
moved to Cairo in 1997 when I moved back
to to Cairo from living in France and
London I I did this first sort of major
work that sort of threw me into the into
the art world which was taken from a
commission by the the fundación cafe in
Paris they were preparing an exhibition
that was looking at the history of
photography and how in the and how today
in the beginning of the 20th 21st
century how photography and landscape
were what was the relationship between
photography and landscape so so I did
this piece in a very low-tech
kind of way because in Cairo at the time
and until now actually there is no real
photographic lab or any kind of new
technology applied to photography
so this is c41 analog photographs
there's no Photoshop
I always feel the need to say that it
felt natural at the time but today it
seems like people think I've done this
and Photoshop so if you look at the big
collage this is a three and a half
metres by one and a half metre piece
it's made of six hundred photographs
that are postcard size and on the corner
here you see a photograph by Leonard
Anand rock which is basically I mean
it's the only postcards the actual real
postcard of the of the work which refers
to this Orientalist view of the desert
but then sort of throws a whole new
narrative of picnicking in the desert
and and you and being there as a very
familiar place rather than a place of
adventure and possible deaths and so on
and the characters that I staged my
friends and some veterans were basically
inspired by fairy tales and the whole
sort of mythology of the piece is very
much constructed around the idea of the
separation and of the water and the
earth
and the sort of emergence of humanity
the next work that I move into was Sam
Dougal dunya which means the world in a
box which is actually the the sort of
ancestor to to filmmaking to movies
which is sort of theatrical Pandora
moving box I'm not sure if it has a name
in English but it would be like a kind
of ambulance theater where people you
know somebody would sort of bring
narratives to your door and you would go
as a kid and listen to them in the
street and just sit down on the sidewalk
and listen to them so this was called
sambucol dunya and and here I'm taking
the counterpoint of the previous work
and sort of throwing myself into a kind
of apocalyptic urban landscape using
characters from my childhood and you
know what Western as well as Middle
Eastern television so I don't know if
you've all seen this gerund I so
remember him even this is one of the
first Transformers in the 80s and so I
sort of inspired myself with manga
characters to create a whole whole
narrative around the idea of video games
and how video games are themselves
inspired by board games and in this case
I'm amusing snakes and ladders here you
have a detail of a fight taking place in
a staircase and I should I shot
everything in my service staircase from
my home apartment in Cairo it was quite
funny because it was during Ramadan and
so everybody sort of came to the to the
to the the street underneath and could
see it from you know from could see
Assam the balconies and and so all the
kids because there's lots of schools
around my house they were all joining up
and trying to get into the into the
building and to to come to actually
touch the characters and it was it was
very amusing you know interaction with
the street and and because even my
neighbors sort of would open the door
and say oh god this one oh I prefer the
one from yesterday you know so it was
this kind of like okay and I mean they
were quite outrageous in the middle of a
very kind of Cairo environment this is
another detail of the piece and here
there is in the catalogue was a kind of
mock-up the idea of the video game and
how you sort of choose your characters
and then they fight each other and so on
and so there's in fact this is a sort of
psychological portrait of a woman in a
contemporary city so each of these
characters is actually one character and
they're all sort of collapsed into one
one with my favorite one which is the
Golden Age and played by my grandmother
in 2007 I had access and the possibility
because I had that idea a few years
before but I couldn't really do it in
Cairo but I had access to this
possibility of applying this new recent
technology that was developed in Belgium
to make tapestries from digital files
from digital stills and so what I did is
photographed the original collage which
is made of a thousand photograph edited
themselves from about 10,000 photographs
that I took and stitched the photographs
together back into a reproduction of the
collage and then that that image was
done
digitally woven through quite an
elaborate machine so here you see
details of how this work becomes
transformed into an actual material and
silk and wool and a mix of different
materials this is another detail and
this is the machine so you see how both
of my collages when we Came tapestries
that's the scale of it just to give you
a sense of and then I had a bit of
overdose of photographs so I sort of
moved away from from shooting in analog
printing these massive you know I would
come back with suitcases of prints from
the lab and like you know spent days and
days and days attending them but I sort
of got kind of overdose with it and
decided to move into using photography
and sort of you know get out of the
frame of the photograph and also used
you know the what you call the qualities
and the possibilities that were given to
me in Cairo so very extraordinarily you
know you have no access to a lot of
Technology and a lot of modernity but on
the other hand you have people who do
things with their hands and you have
people who and you can access a hospital
for example and go and do x-rays of
whatever and have you know because
you're the doctor is a friend of your
somebody in your family and so you can
sort of do things that would be very
complicated to do it in different
context and so I built my first
installation which is I know you don't
think in meters but 29 meters is pretty
big so this is the circumference of the
piece seen from above and it uses an
Islamic star which is a the expansion in
Sufism it's the expansion of the compar
the breadth of the compassionate and
here I'll stop talking a little bit so I
can show you a little taste of where I
come from
the sound is very low on this but I'm
not sure if we can adjust it here
so this is 2002
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on collapsed where were we
sorry about though hope it works
oh that's fine my fly my file must be me
no let me see the pastor the bit that's
not happy also it's so it okay so it cut
it cut it didn't convert the whole video
okay no problem we'll move on here you
can see what it looks like at the end
and it's basically a lightbox which I'm
sorry about this
it's a lightbox with with lights that
turn on and off so they sort of animate
the images like like in a magic lantern
so the narrative you have to walk around
to see the narrative and it's a
continuous narrative so the images are
images of plastic dolls that look like
fake Barbies but one of them is pregnant
and so her tummy pops up and that's for
Suvi today Tommy sort of opens up and
then the baby crawls out them becomes an
adult and life repeats itself and so it
was a sort of metaphor in 2002 and the
Intifada started it was a way for me to
kind of do a metaphor of how history
repeats itself and how peace war sort of
follow each other and in a continuous
and ever and never-ending sort of circle
it was also a sort of way of referring
to the overpopulation of Egypt and as a
kind of also staging the funnels from
the you know in parallel to this very
important landmark which is the Muhammad
Ali mosque which everybody knows and
which has this huge Lantern in it my
next videos will work I hope which what
what is this which one is that
hold on oh that's another one okay
no we don't want you so then I so what
I've done is really I've tried to focus
on selecting works that would make sense
in terms of the work I'm doing here but
also in terms of how living in Egypt and
having made that decision very
intentionally I've sort of always played
with this possibility of bringing very
kind of direct and simple materials with
the possibility of using new
technologies are trying to work with
this you know trying to transform
photography and narratives with other
other tools than the ones that were I
had access to in Cairo so here this is
an image of an installation of a work
called shish kebab so she's looking at a
screen inside the box and it's a it's
like a music box so when you open the
box you the screen the the the film
starts and it's like a ballerina running
around Tokyo and when you close the box
at any time then the the music stops
just like a traditional music box so
this this work was I'm showing it here
because it was 2003 and it was during my
fellowship in Japan and I had never done
I had I didn't have a mobile phone by
then it was still the beginning of
mobile phones but I overnight like got a
mobile phone like plastic in Japanese
mobile phone totally non you know
complicated to use but the thing about
being in Japan at the time was that they
already had internet on their phones I'm
not sure when it came in in the US that
you could actually have so when did it
start do you remember
right so so in Europe it was not yet the
case and definitely not in Egypt so it
was quite funny to be in Tokyo and to
have this this toy as part of one of my
ways of collecting images and stories so
I completely
you know I just documented every single
second of my life so these are like you
know peace those you can see them here
so this is one of them so this was made
for with mobile phones and the funny
thing is I found the system because you
couldn't connect the phone which is of
course Japanese technology to my
computer which was not Japanese
technology so I had to find a way to
download those photos so when I would
take the metro I would like write an
email to myself and attach maximum I
could attach two photos and so I would
attach two photos and then when I would
arrive at the platform where there was
internet I would send an email to myself
so I did this with like three thousand
photographs which was kind of insane but
you know I think it's kind of funny to
think about this today and to think that
this is like torii normal for us today
but it wasn't them I even had a crazy
conversation with the curator that was
my adviser in Japan who was like what
are you gonna do with the stuff you know
it's like super low resolution and you
can't do anything with it I was like I
don't know and I just think I have to do
this so this is what sort of comes out
of it and then at that time I was also
it was also the beginning of the Iraq
war so it was like being submerged with
cranes and relationship to this kind of
very clinical way of looking at reality
and to constantly be looking at a screen
whether it was my computer to look at
the news or whether I was in Shibuya in
the middle of Tokyo like where a screen
is reality and every building is every
facade of the buildings art screens and
so this whole relationship also of how
wars represented and how you know and
how how random it is also how how
unimportant it was in Japan because
suddenly also I wasn't in the center of
the world as I was always used to you
know being living in Europe or living in
the Middle East always gave me the sense
that you know Europe and what the West
is always this kind of you know you see
the world from that point of view and
suddenly in Tokyo it's like no one even
knew what Iraq was or where it was they
really care to be honest so it was this
very interesting sort of shift of how
cultures become kind of alienated or not
this is a view from from the top of the
museum and then from this work also and
it is very interesting for me to show
this here because I think it's kind of
the anchor to what I'm doing here is
this piece called Rebecca Rebecca and
Italian means Bragman
it comes from the presence of the
Italian community in Egypt in the 50s
and on til the 50s and it's then used
today as you know in in countries like
India or Egypt or Africa you always have
someone who has a job that sort of walks
around the street and announces either
sell something or buy something or does
or sharpens knives or you know this kind
of very tiny very niche sort of works
and Rebecca is the Ragman is the man who
passes through the streets and collects
old junk and so this work was done with
I was interested in showing how after
this experience of like massively
producing nonsensical images really of
Japan I you know 50 hours of videos and
like thousands of photographs of about
mobile phone and so on I I wanted to
sort of you know deal with digital trash
so what is all this you know what we do
with this oldest digital production and
so the notion of digital trash as well
as the notion of how we perceive history
was very much what I was trying to
answer in this work and this is a view
from the other side of the Kaleidoscope
the life-sized kaleidoscope
it shows how instead of putting instead
of using video which was which would
normally be the way of installing a work
in an art context and having it loop and
again and again so whoever comes will
sort of catch it at whenever it happens
I really wanted to keep the randomness
of the kaleidoscope and how the
kaleidoscope is never creating the
pattern so the sort of archetypal
structure is there but the pattern is
always different and our experience of
life is always different although we are
all exposed to similar sayings we tend
to understand them experience them in
different ways so I wanted to look at
this this notion of how we tell stories
and I sort of found a text by Benjamin
that was describing a little bit that
the kaleidoscope as a as you know he was
using the analogy of the optical tool
the kaleidoscope as an optical tool and
as a way of looking at history and how
in fact we write history with the
leftovers of history and so I used my
digital trash to sort of kind of
recreate in this environment where you
get all these stories again and again
but never the same way twice and so this
was my first use of working with coding
and computers and avoiding sort of the
traditional way of making a video and so
my cousin happily was a coder and Joe in
Copenhagen and we worked together via
Skype and PCs and Mac and it was also
quite funny because at the time it was
like almost impossible to to even
connect on the Internet and this is the
same work shown in Dubai and the first
art affaire that now is very established
so the outside is mirrors and the inside
is mirrors and so people go in and
become part of the piece so here you
have an Emirati experiencing it
this is a it's a very difficult piece to
photograph because you're photographing
mirrors so it's never really focus but
in here you can have a little sense of
how it sort of moves so these are just
samples of moments within the the
movement of the of the the images inside
the structure there's no sound so no
words
see this is the back of the of the work
and from the other side people who could
enter the the kaleidoscope
and so the way the code worked is that
it went from one set of selected images
and then chose randomly twelve of them
and then threw them out as you saw in
that grid and then moved on to the next
series of images and again selected
another twelve and so on and so forth
today my videos are not happy so never
mind you get the idea and so the so the
that you know that way of telling
stories and using archive as well as
this whole relationship to history that
we have was very much already anchored
in this work in a much more kind of you
know in this way of abundance and this
era of digital that we were in while
also in in Egypt being perceived it was
very interesting how it was perceived
because the day before the the opening
of that work there was a sandstorm and
so the whole you know the 21 mirrors
were covered in dust and sand and it was
like it was a total disaster and so it
was really like a whole race to kind of
clean everything up and make it work by
the time the opening would start and it
really looked like this kind of diamond
that was like digged from under the the
desert and this sort of Stargate that
really had nothing to do there it was
such a contrast between what's happening
in the street with the audience my
conditions and people working the cars
and so on
and this environment so it was quite
beautiful here I'm like looking a little
bit also in the contact so all of this
was happening in the years of between
the 90s and until the end of the era of
Mubarak's dictatorship this is a an
image I kept because I removed this work
but I kept this image just to give you
the kind of also you know a little bit
of an reference to what does happen in
Cairo and where in Egypt is out and how
pretty dramatic some of its aspects are
and this work I did as a this world
series of photographs that I took
to document the architectural patterns
of the suburbs of Cairo the slums that
are called informal architecture because
they're built illegally on agricultural
land and they basically have destroyed
all of the agriculture land Urbanists
say that by 2020 s there won't be any
left and it's a real real environmental
disaster there is no there is no
amenities in those areas and they really
have this very specific kind of dynamics
to it socially politically and so on and
the these cities actually constitute 65%
of Cairo so they are Cairo and so these
photographs became a book but what what
I was doing was to really understand how
these things were being built and how
what was the patterns that were being
used in terms of you know that kind of
system was there a system so how this
was built as I had an idea for the Cairo
international biennial - to actually
build a tower in the center of a
military base which is the UH programs
and middle of Cairo which is probably
the most expensive piece of real estate
in the country and so the subject of the
the biennial was the others and given
how the government wasn't paying
attention to all these areas and all
these people and really to nobody I
thought that would be a really
interesting way of responding to this
biennial and if I'm going to be part of
it I'm going to be part of it as also
making a point of using the space and
for what it means so I did this work
really in relationship to what this
space was how loaded it was politically
and so this is a two storeys high tower
that uses all this details of how these
places are built and it's a kind of
collage of photographs in a way or it's
if you know some people told me it looks
like a tapestry because of how the
bricks are sort of woven and inside was
you can see in the background the Opera
House
you can imagine also the kind of
problems I had building that in that in
that space with all the security guards
sort of like arresting my workers
because of course they're like not
supposed to be there because they're
poor people but then the workers do live
in these areas so they absolutely loved
it and became completely part of it and
and kind of embraced this monument to
the poor as someone called it when the
opening started and so inside the tower
was a donkey Symphony which is I know
sounds funny but it actually is quite
sad and it was it was a symphony
inspired by Gorky symphony from the 70s
in three movement very classical piece
except that we have a sort of dialogue
between Sopranos and donkey brays and
it's and it and it's sort of sort of at
times it's kind of funny at times makes
you cry and people would come in and
never go out and so I also became the
cafe of the Opera ground where you know
you could smoke the shisha and get your
coffee and get your sandwich or your
book and hang out in the space and you
know one day I came and I found a
massive ashtray full of cigarettes and I
asked the security what the hell
happened here you know and I could see
onions piers and like all kinds of stuff
had happened and he said well the
director of the Opera House came with
somebody and they just had a meeting for
three hours this it was quite you know
it was a very very it was a quite an
extraordinary time it was also at the
end of the of the regime so looking back
and in retrospect in retrospect to this
work it was a way of saying you know you
know we have to address issues here and
they're not being addressed so this was
quite a you know I wasn't sure what
would happen from this work so then in
2012 I I actually played the donkey
symphony with I have to give you a copy
with the camera Orchestra of keV which
was probably one of my biggest nightmare
in my life as the Russian chief
orchestra was a fantastic man but
extraordinarily stubborn and hated my
doggies and
hated me for one thing him to play with
this beautiful classic music with my
donkey brays so it was pretty we almost
canceled the whole thing and then these
five ladies came in and they started to
play the from the score the soprano part
of the piece and we were just all in
tears and it was quite magical so we
said okay we're gonna put up with this
and just do it so that was quite an
experience too and here I'm laid the the
symphony and asilo in the art of my
residency last summer and it was
beautiful because the next day it was
also raining and so you had the sound of
the rain with the sound of the donkey's
and the Sopranos I mean it was all very
special in the period of the uprising
and when Tahrir Square became this
international the eye of the world went
on us you know this was again I repeat
myself sorry for those who we were here
last week but it was the most documented
event in the 21st century with as many
people as many cameras and maybe more
cameras than people and you know without
counting also how much the press
actually covered this event and so on so
here you have a sense of you know how
crazy the relationship we have today to
mobile phones and to making images and
stories and so very quickly on when the
revolution started I the first thing the
reason why I went down was this video
sorry you shall do
[Music]
they're screaming courageous courageous
so this isn't this is the second day of
the revolution this is the 26th of
January and for the first time the
people you know were more the presence
of the people was bigger than the
presence of the police in the square and
so this this video I saw was one of the
first viral videos from the revolution
and the kind of confrontation between
this man standing up and not moving and
the cannon the water cannon was a very
shocking kind of moment for it was it
was very much resonating with chairman
and the man standing in front of the
tank in 89
it was actually the title gentleman
Cairo Courage this video and that was
the way I that was the reason why I went
down and I'll stop it here that was the
reason why I went down but it was also
what triggered my what triggered my
interest in the kind of iconography and
relationship to history as well as to
what was happening in the street and
trying to make sense of it so there was
a lot of reason for me to get kind of
carried away with starting this archive
so I didn't really do it because I had
the idea of making an archive I did it
because it was a way of coping with and
making sense of what I was part of but I
also very quickly understood this was
becoming quite a big Enterprise in
itself and I had to start to be
methodical about it and organized and
really like kind of take it to another
level so it's been growing it's a
project that's been growing since 2011
so I've come here with this project now
it's called Vox Populi archiving a
revolution in the digital age the first
the first and that whole period sort of
is full of projects so the first project
is and this resonates with the work
healthy through the mid earlier as we
started working together on this how to
how to deal with the you know with
voices and sound
music from the revolution and the first
project that came out of the archive was
a very immediate and very blunt kind of
project that was born overnight I had
all this material that I had downloaded
from YouTube and I knew very much in my
gut that you know although he was called
the Facebook revolution half the country
didn't have internet and then watch all
this stuff and were still under the kind
of propaganda of Egyptian television so
with somebody in the square I talked
about doing a cinema and then we just
like I built at the town house this
gallery I work with I built this very
rudimentary screen which you see on the
side and the funny thing is behind the
screen is actually a printed image of
the view from the top of Tahrir so it's
like this crazy being there but also
that image is also like sort of
transparent and and that that cinema was
a way of sharing footage of the
revolution that most people probably
didn't have access to but it was also a
way of archiving more the revolution so
people came they took and we spent hours
and nights you know filling people's USB
sticks with the footage that we were
showing and I'm giving us their footage
of whatever fights and battles they had
participated in or witnessed and so we
had the tent in the middle of the sanaya
and which is the center of the
roundabout where we collected all this
material but it was also a way of
communicating about the revolution and
discussing where we were at and and all
kinds of things happened so it was quite
a vibrant place the first sort of the
after the Tahrir cinema which was
dismantled by the army and things
started to get really complicated and
less and less people were going to the
square and the revolution sort of slowed
down I tried to digest everything I had
collected so far and so the the first
for me the first kind of narrative that
really comes out of all this stuff is
this piece that I did alone together in
media rise again I used the same system
as the kaleidoscope where I work I
worked with a coder to to randomly and
this was from your kind of way of also
interpreting how what our relationship
to Internet is and how we all have a
very different relationship to it we can
all Google the same words but we won't
get the same answers so you get what you
get according to what you've searched
before rather than according to a
pattern of archive that's going to be
just given to so so really our
interpretation or relationship or
understanding of history becomes a
completely different one and so and so
the way the piece works is that there's
a there's a linear well there's an
there's a narrative linear I don't know
but there's a narrative that's always
that stays that's always the same so
whoever sees the piece will see the same
narrative but what what works next to
the narrative and the images that come
up are a little bit like in the
kaleidoscope they are chosen through a
series of folders that are tagged and
then from these folders random number
like 15 or 12 again are being pulled out
and accompany the narrative so there's
this kind of system of you know
different experience that we may have so
I won't play the whole thing I'll cut
you in the middle too but you can see
that on the internet it's called alone
together in media res and it's available
I mean there's a small expert that's
available on the on the net but this is
a little bit like the
[Music]
anything
it's barricaded the world with hate has
goose-stepped us into misery and
bloodshed we have developed speed but we
have shut ourselves in machinery that
gives abundance has left us in want
our knowledge has made us cynical within
too much more than machinery we need
humanity more than cleverness we need
kindness
[Music]
so this goes on for it's a forty minute
piece so it's it's a it's a long
narrative that's based on I mean for me
was a way of looking at all the
different questions that were raised as
the events were unfolding on the ground
and kind of address this kind of
archetypal need for revolt and quest for
freedom that that every generation has
and every culture has whoops then we
moved into I move here into the the rule
of the Muslim Brotherhood but it's also
you know kind of mixed with what's
happened also with the rule of the SCAF
which was the Supreme Council of Armed
Forces the army and the very much
focused on there was a huge amounts of
questions and issues in that period but
there was a very clear kind of war on on
women here there's a there's a this
world that was built by the army the
whole of Cairo around Tahrir was just
avenues going down from Tahrir and
blocked by these massive blocks of
cement which of course the demonstrators
destroyed very easily and very often but
a lot of battles happen and this is very
very sad place the Mohamed Mahmoud
Street which then becomes the kind of
street where all the revolutionaries
graffitis artists have painted all the
portraits of the martyrs and the kind of
on overlay stories and stories of
the batter's of the revolution so this
graffiti is there's flowers for all the
people who died but the graffiti is from
the football teams that were very much
the supporters of the Revolution and it
basically says ilhara Gala boot which is
an Arabic freedom is coming but there's
a kind of emphasis on the fact that
there is no it's a certain thing that
freedom is coming and so I used this to
title a piece that I did in metal and
leather so I went back to come of making
a sculpture and I basically built a
chastity belt quite giant size chastity
belt and I'm showing these photos
because I think it's quite amusing to to
see this machine that laser cuts metal
and while I was doing the the work that
place was marred by this group of
Salafis which is a very very very
traditional kind of and fundamentalist
group of Muslims so I of course wasn't
gonna tell them I'm doing a chastity
belt so he they asked you know what is
it you're doing so I said I'm doing
agate and so and so they were really
curious they didn't know what it was but
the funny thing was that this this
machine is a 1 million dollar machine so
when you think about like this kind of
like you know this this object that cost
a fortune that has a diamond to kind of
you know laser cuts in this metal but
then when I get the piece that I made
this is how we go back to the workshop
bring it back in a kind of medieval kind
of way and kind of also medieval
political environment that we were in at
the time and this is the workshop where
I'm doing the lock for the the chastity
belt and here you see the actual piece
finished and shown in an exhibition in
France in 2013 in a funny way where it
was originally created as chastity belts
were pretty much medieval European
invention and this one was actually
inspired by a 17th century french
chastity band so there was also this
whole sense of again history repeating
itself
or the resonance between different
periods and so on and here it's shown in
that km which is center for media and
Technology so it's quite a funny place
to show an object that's so raw
following this object
I took the counterpoint of the chastity
belt and worked back with the archive
and with this environment in which we
were that was really really offensive
aggressive towards women as as people
were really there was no police and
there was no army doing anything they
were just leaving the Brotherhood sort
of do their thing and there was a very
very clear kind of political political
tool being used that was to rape and to
sexually harass women in the street so
they could go back home and so - up to
now there is about 2,500 16 or I don't
know exactly the number but that kind of
number of women that have reported being
sexually harassed or are raped so let
alone the ones who haven't you know I
wanted to show another side of to
respond to the situation in a very
different way and so this image is a is
a still from an installation in in 2013
in Paris at the Grand Palais where I was
commissioned by Christian Dior couture
designer to do a work inspired by Miss
Jo and Miss Dior happened to be an
activist who had been arrested during
the Second World War and who resistant
more than an activist and she when she
came out of the concentration camps her
as her brother created dress for her and
then later a perfume so she's really
like the sort of icon of the Christian
job and also it was interesting that
this woman actually had this kind of
political loaded history and so I
collected as a branching out from my
archive I collected like five hundred
videos of women from the early century
the 20th century from early cinema to
like more or less the 50s that were
really focused on the liberty
of women but also that had changed
something in the fields they were
working in or images in films that
represented the role of a woman of a
certain kind and so the screen you see
is 180 degrees you're surrounded by it
and the sound is a surround sound
systems there are seven speakers five
across the screen in front and two
behind so the whole time every character
that comes into the image sort of feels
like the presence of it is very clear in
the sound and the the work is not to be
looked at as a video as a narrative but
much more as an immersive common a kind
of environment and mood that you become
part of so here there's a not sure how
long this this is but we can start you
have to imagine it's ten meters by three
which I'm not sure how to convert in
inches but it's two and a half the size
of a human being high and pretty long so
you can never see the whole thing at
once you have to constantly turn your
head left or right
[Music]
so in a space you see every single
character is very in detail of course
this is very reduced
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so in this space of course she looks
like she's coming back behind you and so
this is an eight-minute piece I'm not
going to show you the whole thing but
you have to just imagine that you're
immersed in it or maybe after that sense
[Music]
voila this is the Muslim Brotherhood
period
it was like my way of saying no and
today we're back to a military regime
which I thought I would illustrate with
this quite vanity image because my name
means kitsch and we were talking about
the meaning of it so it means trouble
and Danish but I just found out today so
we're back to a military regime and it
feels like we can't do very much I mean
there is a very policed country and
anybody who tries to even conglomerate's
more than two or three people get
tear-gassed immediately and arrested and
so on and there isn't anymore the
possibility to kind of go to the streets
as we did or obviously that has its
limits as what it can do and so it feels
a little bit and I'm I'm talking for a
lot of people and in terms of activists
and NGOs and people who have
participated in the revolution that the
work that is really being done at the
moment is archiving and making sure that
at least that period doesn't disappear
doesn't get censored as it already has
been very much so and also that it gets
recorded for and in some cases those
records do constitute an actual
political tool and put it a potential
political power against the regime so so
this is the kind of moment we're in
where archiving is a kind of you know
taking a step back but archiving becomes
a very important way of resisting so I I
know archiving sounds sometimes a little
bit you know like maybe boring because
it's about organizing and putting things
away and so on but but I think it's very
important to also see how archiving has
had so many different lives and how
there are ways to deal with archive and
how see was presentation earlier today
was really amazing in that
that it it allows the you know the
platform he developed really allows for
four stories to continue to exist and to
remain alive and so the the work I'm
doing here today which is here is a sort
of like first kind of iteration of
possibilities and how and how data kind
of dialogues with itself it's very much
trying to do I mean originally it was
one big project I think it always is but
the way to to construct it is really to
kind of divide it into sub projects so
that it can actually get somewhere and
start to exist as a and manifest itself
so so my vision of it is to influence by
this big painting and this the street
where all these graffiti artists have
painted the revolution over and over and
over again the Mohamed Mahmoud Street
where is so also the wall built by the
army earlier it is very much what and
the amount of documentation digitally
that exists this kind of - this kind of
- for me constitutes the kind of
inspiration for creating what I call a
transmedia painting where data is
orchestrated in a way that it
communicates with itself and it can be
read and interacted with and so that
while it is an artistic interpretation
of a timeline of the revolution in a
very visual very aesthetic with with a
choice of an aesthetic that is very much
the way that the people have responded
and created and produced material on the
revolution so I focused my archive on
Vox Populi which is the title of the
work and on how this you know everybody
became a kind of video artist overnight
and produced material that was uploaded
regularly or created very funny kind of
jokes or slogans or animation I mean all
kinds of material came out of it and so
and
this idea of creating while creating an
installation that really invites people
into reading the timeline is one
timeline rather than as a day-to-day
relationship to an event and also give
them the ability to add their own
commands and an annotation to this what
I call the biography of our memory it is
also it's also been very exciting to be
here because there is and I thank MIT
for that because it's given me the real
access to so many different levels of
questions that are related to my project
so not just the technological
application to making an artwork or
telling a story but also the
understanding of the political context
in which all these things happen and the
the issues that are raised suddenly when
you start creating a project like this
that involves the internet that involves
security that involves the need for
protection of an archival need for
protection of people that are involved
in the archive the you know the legal
aspects the ethical aspects and all
these other questions so these are like
I can go on and on and on about them and
to start this massive idea and like
where do I go and how do I started I was
extremely lucky to meet students and
faculty between MIT and Harvard and two
of them are here so I have Joseph here
and who's created the duck shop which is
a group of students and faculty that
sort of incubate a project in the
context of a university and Halsey who's
one of our also my colleague at open da
cloud who's contributed to using the
sound the sound archive from the from
the archive I've collected on the
revolution and together we made at the
end of last semester an event we created
an event that was that whose objective
was really to just present the idea so
rather than doing a
I feel like I'm doing here I wanted to
bring people into the archive into the
idea in a very rudimentary way in a very
rough kind of draft and and just open a
very open conversation about you know
what you know how do you feel about this
does it mean anything to you is there
anything I should focus on you know what
are the possibilities is there are there
other people interested in working with
us on this project and so on and so
forth so the note from Wilson a I was
the first in a way the event zero of an
iteration of possibilities of how to
stage this archive but while staging
this archive proposing a sort of
conversational space as well as inviting
people into the process of observing
records and into the process of creating
art and to each event elaborate on the
aspects of the project until until this
data becomes actually orchestrated in
the way that I have in my in my head so
these are other stills from the event
where you see tweets from the revolution
projected on printed photographs and
I'll pass that and that's it and thank
you very much
[Applause]